[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition a kind of a
cosmic queries
on ai sports march madness
and what happens if we take sports to
other planets
i got chuck with me chuck hey neil all
right and the person who gives
authenticity to the entire concept of
sports edition
gary o'reilly gary hey nia all right an
old
footballer from the uk i was browsing
the internet and i
found a wiki page on you
[Laughter]
right there you were on the soccer field
and you were looking
looking buff and with that sexy
sexy lids baby sexy legs
so uh interested in gary you can dig him
up on the internet
so uh we we don't have particular
expertise in march madness although
we've done a lot of thinking about it
so we have to go to our our a man about
town who thinks about this kind of stuff
and that's matt ginsberg matt welcome
back to star talk
thank you it's great to be back yeah so
matt is like was a
wonder kind with getting his phd in math
at age 24
from oxford excuse me god you're such a
slacker
expert okay i took a year off at caltech
okay and research mathematical physics
my wife's specialty is mathematical
physicist mathematical physics
uh you're a scientist an entrepreneur an
author you've got a
book out there a fictional book the
factor man i like
fiction that is deeply informed by math
and physics
in the universe and that's one such book
where you introduced
god's algorithm the secret formula that
will solve
all uh all the problems of the world and
who
and the fight to take command of it
i love that maybe we'll talk about it
later i love where that's going
also one of your companies what else
excuse me
excuse me yes i think those are called
what are they called
humble when you hear someone say
well one of my companies not all of the
companies right
just one of them no it's just i get i
get bored
so i start a company and okay and it's
like oh i gotta go do something else and
i start another company
and that's why i have this you know
trail
that's good so so the the the the inside
another humble brag
yeah yeah matt just shut up there just
just stopped it
like you know what uh some people when
they get bored they turn on television
when i get bored i start a company
we're the potato chips
you provide statistical support for
professional sports teams
in fact we delved into that topic the
last time you were a guest
i'll invite people to dig up that
episode and what i
love about what i learned in that
episode is you wrote a computer program
that can enter uh crossword
puzzle competitions and it's called get
this
dr phil nice f-i-l-l very
very clever so uh anyhow matt let's get
let's get straight to march madness
they're brackets
you know teams win they it's win or go
home is that right it's not
it's like single elimination last i
checked
and is there any way to predict the
whole thing that you know of that you've
invented
that you can share with us and if so how
how do you how do you use it and what do
you do
do we all need a phd in math to make
that happen can we get warren buffett's
money
so there you go can we really get
warrants
get right down to the basic question
so my understanding is that in order to
get warren buffett's money
you have to predict every single game in
march madness
right and so i actually looked at this i
knew we were going to talk about this
that i looked at this last night
and i think people look at this
as you know what are my chances of
winning and the answer is they're
basically zero
and i looked at it the other way around
and i said let's say
but the chance of winning would be the
chance of getting every single
game predicted correctly okay so if
you're if you're even money on any
particular game
then you have you know you have one
chance one time and two to the 64
will you actually get them all right and
to the 64 is some
giant number so you have no chance but
computers are helping us make better
predictions
so i thought okay what if i wanted to
have a one in a thousand shot
which it's still not terribly good
but it means that if i get to try 20
times
then i have a 1 in 50 chance of actually
getting it sometime in the next 20 years
which is sort of as far out as i can
look
and it turns out that in order to have a
one in a thousand
shot at winning warren buffett's money
you have to be able
to predict with 90 accuracy who's going
to win any particular game
and some of the games that's pretty easy
right when a one seed plays a 16 seed
and you bet on the one seed it's
probably about 90 percent so that's good
the problem is when the seven seed plays
the eighth seed
yeah that game is really a toss up and
getting to the point that you can
predict that game with 90
accuracy is really hard there are
computer methods
that will help those computer methods
one of the nice things about them is
they'll actually tell you how
how sure they are so you can put in all
this information about two teams and say
they're playing
well did you get to put in how are the
players
feeling today i mean isn't that a factor
that you're not considering here
it is and you can put in
obviously i i mean you could call them
and ask i don't know that that would
actually
help um it would help them
you know hi it's matt just want to know
how you're doing today
there you go and um if they took the
call
then you could make some judgments um
i think that that a lot of the
information that you need is actually
buried there
so for example one of the things that
i've you can put in whatever you want
so you can put in for example how many
minutes of playing time
did this guy have over the last three
weeks
that's very important and that's sort of
a proxy for how
tired is he yeah and you can put in how
many minutes do you have the last three
weeks of the last three days
when was he last injured how has he been
playing
recently so all of this information is
public
and you can at least in theory
push it all into a machine learning
system
and out will come i think this team is
going to win
and the probability is whatever
wow now how
they typically for a problem like this
they typically use something called
gradient boosting and that doesn't
really help you much
um what they do you mean is hearing you
say that it's gradient boosting doesn't
help as much well does crazy and
boosting not help
much i know which which is it that
doesn't help
radio boosting is very slick what it
does is it says
okay give me tons and tons of data about
march madness
historically going back as far as you
have it just
buckets of data and then it says okay
i have data on
400 000 games i'm going to
take a thousand of those games out
and not look at them and i'm going to
set them off to the side
and then it tries to figure out what
tendencies there were
in the 399 000 games it has left
and then it says okay this is what i
think is going on and then you go and
you get the thousand games and you bring
them back in
and you check and you see how well did i
predict
right now in order to get warren
buffett's
money because that's the uh that's the
objective of this whole program no it's
not going to be in a second
in order to get warren buffett's money
you need to predict these
seven versus eight games with ninety
percent accuracy
in order to get vegas's money you
probably need to predict them with sixty
percent accuracy
so if you're that good at predicting
who's going to win these games
you should go to vegas you shouldn't you
should not try and win warren buffett's
money it's a much
it's a much further reach and it's not
that much i mean it's a million dollars
right
right yeah for a year for the rest of
your life
if you can predict you can get that
money from vegas and it's easier
right if you can predict 60 of the time
because you just come back every year
and you get the money you get the vegas
money every year
but matt if we use that model you've
just described it talks to me about
history
now from a player's point of view that's
great it means nothing to me because
we're not playing those teams those
players are no longer playing we're
different players
this for in my mind that's history it
has no relevance
to what is about to happen if you look
back historically
you will see that his that five years
ago
lebron james scored way more points than
average and yes that's history
but it certainly bears on today i mean
he was just a better player
and you can you can also look and you
can gather information about
how right now today he sucks right yeah
how old is he how do people age how do
people
like lebron age and you can just
there is so much data now now what makes
it hard the reason people don't just go
beat up on vegas with this stuff is
because
there's so much data in something that
happens
with machine learning when you have too
much data
programs start what's called overfitting
which means
they look and they say wow whether or
not the lakers won last year
was correlated with the phase of the
moon oh dear
and that's probably that is history and
that's just
luck but if you have so much data some
of it's going to look relevant when it
really isn't
and the reason machine learning is hard
is because you have to somehow filter
that out you have to somehow say
which of this actually matters and one
of the
reasons people have this thousand games
off to the side
right is because then they say wow the
lakers in the phase of the moon and look
at the thousand games and it's like
that didn't work right and then they go
and they try again so you're using the
the data uh itself as part of the
predictive model
kind of like what they do with climate
you you put in the history of climate
to show whether or not the predictive
models that you're using right now
are effective yeah that's right that's
right that's right but
so just i want to emphasize something
that you said matt
um and you said it brilliantly and
beautifully
i i don't want it to go by without sort
of adding further
punctuation if you put in
there's there's a point beyond which you
have so much data
that you can find car relations
that have nothing to do with cause and
effect and
and so you need enough ways to check
against that
to remove those correlations from the
analysis
is that a fair way to to summarize some
of what you just said
it is and and the effect is very real i
mean you can you can go online and you
can
you can look for weird correlations and
you know it's things like the number of
loaves of bread
eaten in each year in denmark is
incredibly well correlated with whether
the u.s stock market goes up or down
something you know they're
they're just craziness and and as
chuck said it really is a matter of you
have
there are words for it so you have one
set of data it's called the training
data
and that's the data you use to build
your model and then you have this other
set of data which is called the
validation data
which is the data that you use to test
your model and see if it actually
turned out to work and
it's what you can't do what it seems
like you want to do
is when you train your data and you look
at the validation
data and it doesn't work because you
were looking at the number of loaves of
bread eaten in denmark
so you make a new model that doesn't
consider denmark
and you try that on your validation data
and it doesn't work and then you do it
again and again and again until you find
something that works on your validation
data
well you've cheated now your validation
data is sort of dirty because you've
been using it over and over and over
again
and your basic models think they're
working with just the training data but
you're working with the validation data
right so you're stuck
right so you need you need clean data
and clean data is incredibly valuable
because what happens you have these four
hundred thousand games feels like a lot
and then you take ten thousand aside and
say uh i'm going to hold them for
validation and you notice oh maybe
that's not enough i need
i need another validation set and you
take ten thousand
more aside and then you take ten
thousand more aside and
and once you touch data it's dirty
forever
so how you split data up between
validation
and training data turns out to be
important and hard
and it really matters that you
not look at your validation data very
often
how many relevant data points would you
expect someone
to want to use for a decent outcome
it depends on what you're trying to do
some things
you need huge data sets so if you're
trying to predict
with ninety percent accuracy seven
versus eight you need
at least as much data you need
everything if you're trying to predict
if a number one seed is going to be the
16 seed you probably
buy a much less so different problems
require
different amounts of data the one by the
way somebody
somebody or some committee seated the
number one team
as number one and the number 16 is
number 16.
so they're using data to do that yep
yes so so you're not you're not
approaching those two teams
from a pure you you are already biased
by the setup for that and i remember as
a kid
and i would i didn't i was kind of very
literal
and they would say oh uh oklahoma
upset texas today by beating them in a
basketball game and i say
of course they upset them because they
lost yeah and so i didn't know
just the concept of upset was not
didn't i didn't understand that it's
because you won
beyond the expectations of some group of
people who decided that you should have
lost
so does that add another sort of
variable of unpredictability to what
you're doing
sort of i mean the bottom line is that
the the seating committee of the nc
2a bracket is looking at very limited
amounts of data they're typically
looking at who be whom and
perhaps by how much yeah and they look
at the you know how well
those teams do and the records of your
opponents but it's a it's a
tiny amount of data relative to
everything you actually could use like
how long have people rested who's
injured where are they playing if i uh
oh no or not or not and because if they
were accurate
no one would ever be upset yeah in a
tournament
correct and right the only person who
would be upset would be warren buffett
because
he would keep losing but
um probably the data you would use if
you were trying to do this seriously
is a vast superset
of the data that the march madness guys
you know the nc2a guys
actually use there's um
there's something else that i think it's
important to to realize here
and i think uh
and this has to do with how people solve
problems and how machines solve problems
so
i often draw a distinction between what
i like to call a 99
problem and a 49
problem so in a 49 problem
you're trying to distinguish between a
49 probability
and a 51 probability so the stock market
if you can only invest in stocks that
are 51
to go up you will make a killing because
you'll just you know the stock market's
50 50 and just
that little edge you'll do phenomenally
99 means you have to just get it right
so this
my sort of standard example of a 99
problem
is stop lights if you identify 99
of stoplights correctly and just drive
through the rest
because you don't realize they're there
you're going to die
you're going to have an accident you're
going to die so
machine learning the kinds of things i
was talking about turns out to be
really good on the 4951 problems and
really bad on the 9900 problems
basketball is interesting right because
it's sort of in between
the stock market is on one side traffic
lights on the other side people turn out
to be pretty good at the 9900 problems
and we're not so good at the 4951
problems
so the the answer the answer is we're
not getting that money
single-minded
[Laughter]
the answer is you're probably not you
might
go go for it yeah
yeah go send your spend your mortgage
money i don't want to dash your hopes
right exactly yeah go ahead chuck go
ahead
bet your kids 5 29.
guys we got to take a quick break but
when we come back this is really a
a patreon cosmic queries
for march madness and i want to get a
few of those questions in
uh related to that but also
uh maybe we can think about sort of
sports on other worlds
and what that might be like when you
return
we're back star talk sports edition
march madness that's what we're talking
about i got chuck and gary here guys
yes yeah we can't do this alone we
needed someone who could
bring the analytics into the house and
we've got our fame
favorite analytic guy matt ginsberg matt
always good to have you here
on star talk with his with his math phd
just spilling it out whatever he's got
to do it
plus i want to tell i want to take
sports off world and see where that can
where that goes too oh cool with
questions that patreon members have
but so all this cred you have
mathematically do you ever do you ever
game the system you know with with with
any of your programming
any of your machine learning any of your
mathematical prowess do you ever put
that to work and just say you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead and make a
little little wait wait chuck i have the
answer so
don't wait i can answer for you matt
here so
either he's a miser or the answer to
that question is no
because look at the room he's in
there's no butler there's no staircase
going up to three-level mansion
the dude is just in a regular room so
um it's not it's not
fun right i had a friend who went and
played blackjack in vegas and counted
cards it was very mathematical at the
end of it all he said he figured out
that he had made
15 cents an hour and
it's such a grind and i i like i'll tell
you
the the best it's a grind making money
it's such a grind
oh the best thing that ever happened to
me
in terms of mathematical abilities is
my daughter uses me as a calculator so
i'll be walking around the house and
she'll dad what's 17 times 36
and occasionally we have house guests
who look at her and they say scott
did you just use your father as a
calculator and she said yeah that's what
he's for
so that's great well guess what
how old is your daughter well now she's
22.
okay i was going to say because at this
point she's using you as a cash machine
dad can i have 17 times 36 worth of
dollars that's right
that's cool all right well that's a good
answer yeah all right
so so give me that chuck who's got the
first uh patreon question
um i don't care gary you want to go all
right yeah i'll jump in so these are
patreon patrons our exclusive patreon
patrons nancy diaz
she says here's a shot at march madness
question how can ai take into account
things like motivation
styles of play and performance under
pressure or other factors
challenging to quantify in determining
the outcome the example she cites is
virginia's national championship when in
2020
given their embarrassing loss in 2019.
so
matt what do we think um is this sort of
enrolled in your
in your data points that we told you
yeah can you quantify motivation
probably i mean in theory you can sort
of quantify anything
motivation probably shows up let me let
me look at this exact example
and you know in the data
is going to be well how well do teams
who got to the finals
do if they lost in the finals the
previous year
you've got a reasonable sampling there
and that's what that can you know and
then these machine learning algorithms
that just
you just drop all the data in and they
just turn it
churn it up and try and look for
patterns and if that's a pattern
it'll find it i've looked for patterns
like that and i've never found them
college athletes seem to sort of always
be about as motivated as they
can be because they love the game
they're trying to get into the pros
they're really working but if there is a
pattern
it should be somewhere buried in the
data and you should be able to pull it
out
interesting wow okay all right that's
pretty cool
actually and so what hap what happens
when you have a team of
four starting freshmen because there
won't be any data on them
so there's there's data on a variety of
things
there's there's data on for starting
freshmen yeah
wait wait wait you have the whole season
behind them what did you have
about to say you have the whole season
behind you by the time you get to march
madness
right um you have data on how does a
freshman's performance
in march madness compare to where that
freshman's performance over the course
of the season
do freshman choke right that's okay
exactly that's exactly a point that you
need to recognize
whether or not the this the occasion
crushes
the player and one of the things that's
that's cool about
these machine learning algorithms like
gradient boosting
is you don't have to figure out
what you're looking for in the data you
just pour all the data in
and the algorithms figure out oh this is
a pattern oh that's a pattern
and they do the mental heavy lifting
for you now they're stupid so they might
find some patterns that aren't really
there
and that's an issue but that's what this
validation data is for so you
in theory they are these very general
purpose
algorithms that are capable of finding
the signal in the noise
got it so so it's not as though you are
quantifying
the thing itself is you're looking at
the statistics
in the larger data set of the
manifestation of that
of that motivation right so uh so in
other words
you can't go up well maybe you can go up
to the one person
see they're really jacked they gave a
really good pep speech pep talk the
coach gave a
crept talk and now they're just gonna
win
you can't put that in after the fact
right you don't know that
you're not adjusting these these correct
the statistics in real time you have to
go in
with the bet already placed i have to
decide what data i want to put in
and train the thing and then
what comes out is sort of how i'm going
to make my bets right
and i'm not because motivational coaches
can have their
influence as well but that will be there
right because you'll see oh this coach
players playing for this coach
do a little better when the same players
went and played for a different coach
so this coach must be good i don't know
if it's motivation
right so i could imagine a world where
for some strange reason on your 18th
birthday
you can't play sports you just you
become uncoordinated on your 18th
birthday exactly and then it gets better
in the data that might look like
freshmen occasionally have a bad day
because they turn 18 on their
somewhere and i wouldn't know if
freshmen tend to choke because the
pressure gets them and they behave a
little bit less evenly
or freshman or there's this miraculous
18th birthday thing
now if their birthdays were in there
well then i would see oh look it always
happens to people
on the day they turn 18 and then it's
because they got [ __ ] faced
that night of their birthday well that
might be the reason but
it's the thing
everything is lurking in the data it's
very difficult to imagine a phenomenon
that that both matters and
is not somehow present in the data
for you to tease out if only you knew
how to look so that's the lesson here
that's it really
yeah all right let's that is the lesson
all right let's let's fly this thing out
of the earth's atmosphere shall we uh
abby chris
heyo experts he says i've been watching
the expanse
which made me think how we could we
conduct basketball tournament with
people who are from
various planets and asteroids that have
been settled by humans like for example
champions of mars versus champions of
jupiter's moon
right now this for me is interesting
because you've got a whole new set of
metrics to factor into your machine
learning here
what are some of the things that we
would need to think about to keep the
field equal
and fair for all teams love the show and
everything keep informing fellas so
you're welcome wow so let me just as a
way of lead into that
um so so matt when people started
training
for the olympics at high altitude no
it's not another planet it's this planet
but it's a different environmental
conditions
under which their body is getting
trained and now
they all go into the same stadium and
some people outperform the others
so that's just an interesting
realization there
that maybe the environment in which you
train
the gravity the air quality the air
density
the uh that can can definitely show up
in your performance i think that's right
and i don't think
we don't historically i mean i have no
idea what's going to happen when we have
people from mars but historically
we don't try to compensate for that so
you know kenyans win marathons
it's just how it is and and there's but
there's not
anything in the rules saying that any
kenyan entering a marathon has to have
ankle weights
as a as a handicap as a handicap there's
nothing in the nba
to try and make it easier for short
people to play
give him a step shoe
just put a little trampoline for their
dunk
[Music]
so i think that if um
if martians you know people from mars
have some
physical difference that makes them
better at a game
hopefully we will just celebrate with
them probably it sucks to live on mars
so we'll celebrate with them that
they're better
fascinating i love watching marathons
because the people who are so good are
so good
and i don't know of anybody i mean i
never bemoaned
the fact that i'm i'm not going to ever
be a professional wrestler it's just not
going to happen
there's no time there's still time
you're being vicious there chuck and i
mean i mean if we bring it back to this
planet just
temporarily if i have to cross from the
west coast to the east coast and if i am
altitude and we come and play at sea
level there's recovery then there's
oxygenation and ability to approach
these things are these not factors that
are relevant
of course they're relevant just like
home field advantage is relevant
right not anymore because there's no
fans that's right no but
playing it fenway is different than
playing at wrigley field the green
monster matters
and and boston players
boston selects their players in part
because they're looking for people who
have the natural skills
that will exploit the peculiarities of
their park
as did the yankees for so many years
everywhere
the right field line
was one of the shortest of all ball
fields it was something like 296 feet or
something it was very short
and so the yankees had a lot of lefty
sluggers right
that racked in the home runs simply
because of that short
porch out on right field and in fact if
you
you're right matt we don't go back to
the record books and say you know half
your home runs
were 310 feet and they would not have
been a home run in any other stadium but
you happen to play for the yankees so
we're going to subtract those
we don't do that we just allow the
circumstances to be
the expression of that of that ability
so that's an interesting
take on this do you know uh the tug of
war used to be in the olympics
as an as an event and the rule was
everyone in the tug of war had to be the
same
profession they had to be a group that
made sense that they competed together
they all had to be like medical doctors
so they all had to be
you know soccer players they all had to
be policemen or
or and so it turned out that the
mounted police always won because they
you also had to wear your native uniform
and they all had these steel reinforced
boots
and then just realize this is a stupid
event and let's just get rid of it
they're also
all used to pulling on the reins of an
obstinate horse
so like let's go so i mean the closest
i've seen to this my wife
um was a hydroplane racer wow
and wait wait she was a what a
hydroplane hydroplane racer
she was the national champion that's a
thing crap
yes these little boats that fly across
the water and it's
actually it's one of the coolest sports
ever
it is so her class had a weight limit
and she was like the only woman she
weighed way less than everybody else and
they actually
made her put a plate of lead in the
bottom of her boat
right so that she could meet the weight
limit and she hated it
because everybody else you know you're
there and you're
driving and you lean and you move
your whole weight and she could not move
the lead plate
it was just stuck on the bottom of the
boat and she could lean
but she was leaning with much less mass
than why didn't they why didn't they
competing against
load pockets in a vest on her so that
she could lean with the weight and match
other people's
capacities she decided the lead weight
was better i mean she was ridiculously
and she
she's beat them all anyway so she was
fine but um
she's wow she's just not competitive
that's awesome i could have i could have
destroyed you
instead of just beat you
also speaking of home field advantage in
an interplanetary
contest so it would matter
if you played your sport in
on your planet right i mean that would
matter presumably yeah
that would be the the ultimate home
field advantage because you know your
gravity and your air quality
and your your all the peculiarities
of your environment plus neil right if i
have to travel from planet a to planet b
and it's x amount of light years i have
to get there and acclimatize so
therefore it's recovery i'd have to turn
up however many
years years ahead of time
my journey yeah no you know it'll be
it'll be like the
the the the uh what do you call it in
tennis where
there's the four events but they're not
all in the same kind of court
so the grand slam so the so wimbledon is
on grass
yeah and who is it on clay uh is it
right right right running backwards yeah
the french opens on clay and then you
have
the concrete you know at forest hills so
that's interesting so if you if you do
the whole circuit then you need
a combination of abilities so which is
what makes winning the full
grand slam so that's so much more
impressive
than anyone who's only has the talent
for just one
so no that's cool all right let's get
let's get another one of our patreon
patrons okay go ahead
go ahead he is the delightful name of
craig woolhouse
and he is from new zealand where he's
proudly uh flagging up the fact that
they stopped covid congratulations yes
um
if a game of basketball it helps when
you're a tiny island and you don't let
anybody in
okay go on don't tell them that they
won't listen
they're very they're a very proud nation
right he says if a game of basketball is
held on mars indoors with earth's
atmospheric pressure would we finally be
able to dunk it from the three-point
line
and would it count as a three or do we
need another planet
oh i'd like that and we will get
we will get to that answer when we come
back on star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition
cosmic queries we started out with march
madness and now we're thinking about
sports on other planet
planets what role ai could play in
predicting winners
and we've got matt ginsberg with us
becoming a friend of star talk
so it's not your first rodeo with us
thanks for coming back matt
so we're picking up on a question i love
this question if you could restate that
of course it's from craig woolhouse he's
one of our patreon
patrons an exclusive member and he says
if a game of basketball was held on mars
indoors with earth's atmospheric
pressure would we finally be able to
dunk it from the three-point line and
would it count as a three
or d we need another planet and then he
science the one that mj
that's michael jordan came from so uh
hmm your answers please
so matt if you could if you have
anything to add to what i say i'd be
delighted for you to
sort of jump in but on mars there's
about 40 percent
of earth's gravity there so if you weigh
you know 100 pounds
on earth you weigh 40 pounds on mars and
all of your musculature
is accommodating the hundred pounds that
you weigh
so now you only have to sort of move
40 pounds sort of up against gravity so
you can jump higher and but
you cannot so
so you can jump higher and you fall
more slowly oh okay that's the important
part so the hang time
yeah is there okay so if you can jump
higher
and you have good hang time and if you
get a good running start
i'm thinking i didn't run all the
equations on this but i'm thinking
you could dunk from the three-point line
and count it as a three-pointer because
you would not have touched the ground
and the ball wouldn't have hit the
ground
in between the three-point shot line and
and the main basket matt what do you
think of that
i think that's right i mean certainly
from a rules perspective that's the easy
part of the question
um you know you take off from behind the
three-point line it's a three-pointer
i think that whether or not you can
do it um i haven't done the calculation
either i suspect that
um a second is still a second and a
meter is actually what's reduced by 40
percent so you probably can jump like
two and a half times as far
and given that michael jordan can dunk
from behind the three-point line anyway
no no no no no no no no no no no
[Laughter]
what he's actually doing which is not
obvious unless you analyze it
so generally if you're trying to dunk
the point where you're dunking is the
highest part of your arc
because the rim is 10 feet up whereas
michael jordan from the free throw
throw line he is not still ascending at
the point he's dunking
he has already peaked in his parabolic
arc
and he's on his way down so he had to
jump
that high in order to make all of that
happen so if you watch his arc
he's on his way down so it doesn't have
to be sort of the limit
of where you're jumping provided you got
up high enough you could just descend
into the dunk okay i i want to sound
like the smart kids
in this conversation so i didn't do the
calculations either
however i know if we're doing this with
this sort of ability
i'm making the court bigger
and the rim taller the rim higher yeah
i'm raising the bar
i'm i'm stretching the court and yeah
because if i if the hang time is seconds
plural
then it's a different game if we play it
on this
people will be flying out the arena
that's a better game
yeah so wait wait but if you do that
then you're neutralizing all these
interesting features
of the martian basketball court right
well but then again it's
it's more like basketball because we've
kind of made it equivalent in the size
of the core
as opposed to an earth court i know i
think it's it's way more complicated
than that right are you going to make
the hoop bigger
if you're shooting from so much further
away you have to make the hoop bigger
but then the inside game becomes
tremendously different so i think it's
act i don't think you can
you can't rebalance it it's going to be
a different game
all right so here's a very good point
right just to be clear
just again to add emphasis to matt's
point you
shoot the ball at the basket and there's
a certain margin
of error in angle outside of which
you're not going to make the basket
right and that is true in any gravity
right so so that you're not
helped in a lower gravity by this sort
of margin of error
angle so if you're going to shoot from
twice as far away
then you're going to make half as many
baskets because that
if the angle will no longer accommodate
the distance over which
the ball is veering off of course unless
you're steph curry
but that's right but i will i want to i
want to just litigate
steph curry on mars that's a new movie
we got to do that
i just want to litigate one quick point
for you guys to figure out
okay if shooting a ball from behind the
three-point line
is what entitles you to the extra point
why would dunking the ball from behind
the three-point line
still gets you that same extra point as
it's your feet
well no the shot actually happens
at the rim okay no so here it is a guy
standing at the three-point line leaning
forward right
so his hands are inside the three-point
arc and shooting
still gets to three points not only that
you can jump
from behind the three-point line land
inside the three-point line
and it counts as a three point okay so
i'm all about your feet
but it's all about the feet it has
nothing to do with the actual shot it's
just
the exit correct all right gotcha
yeah so technically it works it reminds
me of the the movie
which was it a stupid movie but it was
entertaining where they invented the
ali-oop in the movie
and in the alley-oop it's like is that
legal you know the first alley-oop you
got to look at it and say
did anything happen illegal there i
can't think
it should be illegal but apparently it's
not and we kept it
all right there you go all right cool
all right
another question this is another one of
our patreon patrons james senior
he says uh a question about ai when do
you think we will
actually have ai in a sense of an actual
artificial consciousness also
how would this be achieved would it come
from an algorithm or from actually
uploading the human consciousness into a
computer or by
other means so we've dropped the ball
timeout
uh half time whatever you want to call
it and we're now thinking about ai matt
over to you so
um there's some there's some assumptions
underlying
that question that i don't know if
they're right um
so i i think getting uploaded into a
computer
if if that happens to me before i i uh
before my i guess my warranty is up um
that would be fine with me but i don't
think that counts as an ai that's just
matt inside a computer somewhere so the
question of
of what it is to be intelligent actually
becomes important and interesting
historically the definition of
intelligence was
able to pass the touring test which is
something invented by
british mathematician alan turing and it
basically says
if i'm on one end you're typing into a
computer
and an entity is typing back and if you
can't tell if that entity is a machine
or a person
the machine's intelligent okay
if you get back to what i said earlier
about the 49
versus the 99 problems the machines that
look sort of quote intelligent unquote
are going to be the ones that solve the
49
problems they're going to do things we
can't do
they're going to solve problems we can't
solve
but they're not going to look like us
they're not going to pass the touring
test they're going to
i don't know how they're going to deal
with with traffic lights but it's scary
they're and but they're going to be
great at trading stocks
they're going to be great at predicting
who's going to win sporting events
they're going to be great at predicting
the weather
they're going to do all sorts of things
and help us and they're going to have
something that we
i think will come to think of as
intelligence
that there's not going to be a moment
where all of a sudden they go from not
intelligent to intelligent we're already
seeing that
as machines do predict more and more i
think you're also implying
that we should not hold consciousness
as the metric of whether the thing is
intelligent
or useful or can get the job done that's
right because i don't know what
consciousness is i mean are we
waiting for a machine to say hey leni
alone i haven't had my coffee
that's not that's never going to happen
why would we build machines like that
why would we build machines that are
grumpy and machines that
need coffee well the fantasy always
is that the machine will
come to this state of being
on its own through some evolutionary
process
it will achieve consciousness all right
it will so it
it wasn't designed that way it becomes
that way
through so many experiences that it
is able to decipher for itself that it
indeed
is sentient and conscious so the
the number of times that things happen
in the movies is not
a tremendous indicator of how frequently
they will happen in real life
and i don't i don't chuck he just did
that was just a disc
chuck in case you know i never said it
came from a movie i said it was
allow me to just say fantasy that was a
diss
okay so polite one at that i don't think
it's gonna be
like terminator i think we're going to
find
that these machines are our partners
we can do things we can solve problems
they can't they can solve problems we
can't
and we will collectively do more than
either of us could do
individually and i think and that's now
that's today and tomorrow as far as
will they eventually so completely
surpass us
that we become unnecessary in some way
i don't know maybe in some far-off land
but i
imagine that far off time i imagine that
the team
the man machine team is going to be so
much better and it will grow
we will grow together we will work
together to always do things that we
can't do individually i'm incredibly
optimistic about this
i think although you did say you did say
just to let the record show
that the future of machines probably
won't be a terminator that's i don't
know how encouraging that is because
any terminator at all would be bad yes
yes and i i think that you know could we
we could get there if we worked at it
but that would require
an enormous amount of stupidity by a
relatively large number of people
and that's why it's just probably never
underestimated
exactly because never underestimate yeah
humanity's never proved
that they can do that ever i'm i'm just
wondering matt
if if machines are constantly learning
that
that part where they can't solve the
[Music]
100 problem yeah very well there'll be a
point where they can
and then are we not redundant i don't
know that there will be a point where
they can
they really do they're different so
they're architecturally different right
so we have
a trillion neurons operating on
millisecond time scales yeah
machines have even these massively
parallel machines have
thousands of processors operating on
nanosecond time squares
scales we're different architectures we
should be good at solving different
kinds of problems and i you know could
you eventually simulate a human brain
and computer and make it all
sort of the same but then why would you
is the point yeah i love it i love this
angle on it there's so much there
you know it's like it's like somebody
your your parents for your 18th birthday
buy you a porsche and you say
i only want to use it to drive up the
driveway and get the mail
nobody would do that you're going to use
the porsche as a porsche we're going to
use these
these computers that have abilities we
lack
in the areas where we need help just
learned that i've been using my porsche
wrong all these years
but you got your mail fast
there's the early internet let me get to
my mailbox as fast as i can
we got time for one last question if it
has a quick answer
all right i think i think we've got to
go back to the factor man
and god's algorithm matt ginsberg's book
didn't you want to know something yeah i
just i just tell me what happens
what that's a novel right yeah what is
god's equation
um it's about a guy who finds what's
called god's algorithm
it lets him solve basically any problem
and
my view is that he's anybody who finds
this is it's a race
whether the government kills him or he
takes over the world first
and this guy realizes he realizes he's
in this race he doesn't actually want to
take over the world he
he mostly just wants to go to disneyland
with his kids and
it's about his desire to make the his
his attempted journey to make the world
a better place
before this technology is used to to
mess everything up
so this is a trailer it's supposed to be
fun this is a
this is a um do you have confidence that
such a an equation exists
such an algorithm exists so there's this
is the biggest open question in computer
science is whether such
an algorithm exists and i believe it
does um
confidence is probably a little bit too
strong because i'm in a pretty small
minority
um people occasionally measure it and i
think i think something like 10
of the serious computer scientists
believe it something like that and that
would give you
access you'd be able to tap future
knowledge
of systems that would be without
precedent
in the history of civilization that
would make you all powerful
um then you can move out of your parents
basement where you are right now you say
this is you kneel yes i can
i can go get the battery back out of
quarantine you can get the button up
get the boat i love that get the butler
out of the corner
all right we got to call it quits there
matt ginsberg great to have you back
obviously star talk
sports edition thank you and there's
more to plumb in your
uh in your expertise on these topics and
we'll surely come back to you
on this thank you okay great excellent
and gary
always good to have you man my friend
all right chuck chucky baby
love you there all right i'm neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
bidding you farewell from star talk
sports edition as always
[Music]